I cannot believe you guys are you
finished up the series I mean this is
your finishing up and it's been seven
seasons seven seasons right a big big
big chunk of life yeah we have there's a
picture here of you guys celebrating on
the roof of the house that you've been
shooting on yeah I don't think this
looks like a good idea by the way this
is you is this after you take the last
episode yes that was actually right
after the the final shot and then we
decided to yeah like like take shots on
the roof yeah you know it's just it's
just part of it we're like well you have
to understand the house is so stinky
that you you you want to escape the
stench and the roof is probably the best
place you guys have worked together for
a very long time not just for the run of
the show but you started before that you
were doing comedy on the web is that
right we were we have been together for
quite some time now you had a troupe
what was it called mail or a mail order
comedy like mail like postal me I think
we had this was your flyer for mail
order comedy yes I that Photoshop by me
yeah okay well you're all set yeah it's
good to have skills you could fall back
on hey
you